6 26 on your Finally Friday what's
driving you crazy well you need to get
ready for a week of traffic jams on
Sahara around the I-15 Nevada Department
of Transportation says going to be
partial closures of Sahara in both
directions as well as that flyover exit
ramp from the south 15 to go east on
Sarah over towards the strip so in
addition to striping lanes and putting
in those raised pavement markers crew is
going to be kind of putting the
finishing touches on all the work that's
been going on there off and on for
months so the work is scheduled to be
mostly in the overnight hours 9 P.M to 7
A.M starts Sunday night runs until next
Friday morning but when that work
continues after 5 a.m well you know
there's going to be more cars on the
road more backups more frustration it
all can be avoided if you plan ahead and
think about getting off the South 15 at
either Charleston or Spring Mountain
Desert Inn is also an East West
alternate route buckle up drive
carefully please put down that phone you
can join join the driving you crazy
conversation we are traffic 8 at
8newsnow.com